now there are renewed fears for the
health of Germany's Chancellor after she
was seen shaking again it's the third
time in the past month that Angela
Merkel has been seen in public in this
condition this latest occurrence
happened as the Chancellor stood with
Finland's visiting Prime Minister aunt
Irene while watching military honours to
mark his arrival we'll get more from DW
political correspondent Fabian la fonda
mark welcome Fabian and what more can
you tell us well what was already said
she had these incidents before it was
always in situations like that where she
had to stand still the first time it
occurred when the Ukrainian president
Solinsky was in Berlin at that time it
was a very hot day in Berlin so
maritally herself said afterwards that
she drank three glasses of water and
fell fine afterwards and that she was
obviously dehydrated and at that time
that was very understandable for
everyone but then a week later she had a
similar incident and that was inside it
was cool and so that was the moment when
people started to speculate and worried
a little bit because one always has to
bear in mind Angela Merkel has a
reputation for being in very good
physical conditions she has hardly ever
missed a day due to illness and so this
third incident now today is somewhat
irritating for many year in Germany and
so what is the Chancellor saying well
she held this press conference she
seemed perfectly fine and she was
laughing and she also said that she had
met the Finnish Prime Minister just a
couple of days ago ago at the longest EU
summit ever so just to give you an idea
of her her schedule lately and then she
was asking this press conference
directly on on the shaking and maybe we
can just listen what she said to this
I'm fine I said recently that I've been
dealing with this since the last
military honours with president Solinsky
this is obviously not completed but I've
made progress and I will have to live
with this for a while but I feel very
good and there's no need to worry about
me yeah so this is the
such of Angela Merkel I'm fine there's
no need to worry but obviously there are
people that do worry about her so
clearly this is a personal issue for the
Chancellor but she is the Chancellor
there are political implications and
ramifications yes I mean one has to say
that in Germany there's a culture of
great respect in dealing with personal
matters health matters like this and we
haven't heard a politician for example
demanding more information on these
incidents and it might as well be that
she just goes on holiday now later in
the summer she will go on holiday relax
and come back and everything's fine I
mean we know that she has already said
that this will be her last term in
office and so far she hadn't had to skip
any of her appointment she held her
schedule as planned every day even
during those those little incidents so
maybe she just returns and everything's
fine from holiday if not those questions
will remain on her her state of health
calendar Fonda masks thank you